this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
now at five we are on top of breaking
news of a military jet crash in the
northeast part of the valley
we do know the pilot did not survive
this is video from viewer christian
mendoza and you can see clearly
there's large plumes of black smoke as
that
jet crashed into property there on the
northeast part of the valley so thanks
for joining us here at five
i'm denise valdez bryan loftis joining
us from t-mobile arena tonight hi brian
hi there denise that's right here at
t-mobile arena where the golden knights
will look to finish at the fortress
tonight in game five
versus the wild we'll have live coverage
of all the pre-game festivities but for
more on that breaking news back to
denise
all right brian so we'll tell you more
about that crash happened on the south
side of nellis air force base along
north christie lane which is in a
neighborhood near washington and nellis
that's where we find joe moeller who's
been live on the scene since this broke
after three o'clock today shortly before
3 i should say
joe what can you tell us
denise what we've learned so far is that
one person has died in this
crash here that's according to the clark
county fire department we are on
christie lane i'll give you a live look
here
in this residential area you can take a
look just down that street the plane
crashes to the left
of your screen there in a lot in that
area of kerry and nellis now heavy smoke
could be seen in the air following the
crash
we got a lot of pictures and video into
our newsroom a photo was sent to 8 news
now courtesy of taylor grimm
and even more smoke and police cars
could be seen in the video
sent to 8 news now by christian mendoza
now there are several people in this
area stopping by just trying to figure
out what exactly happened theresa nelson
one of them we talked to her
and she explained what she saw i was
sitting in my car
and i heard a plane go by and then i
heard another
plane but it didn't sound normal you
could tell there was something wrong
with it
so i looked at it and it was coming down
very fast and it was
pretty low and the plane was at a tilt
like this and you could tell that he
probably couldn't get juice forces back
up in time
and it just went boom crashed
into a house i saw the black smoke i got
pictures of that
that was crazy because you could tell
there was something wrong with that
plane
it was making it was funny noises
now back out here live we're looking at
the intersection of christie and judson
officials from
metro and also from nellis air force
base are gathering underneath that tent
there on christie lane which is just
east of the lot where this crash
happened
we spoke to a number of people out here
who kind of had similar stories as
teresa you just heard there many people
saying they just
i heard a loud boom went outside and saw
that plume of smoke and the power went
out in this area
so a lot of people just wondering what
exactly is going on but
officials from metro did come by a short
time ago so they're going to be briefing
us as soon as we get more information
from them we'll be sure to pass it on
i'll send it back to you in the studio
joe thanks for that uh now let's check
in with orc omana who's actually just a
few blocks away he's got a different
vantage point of that crash orco
well denise we are getting a little more
detail from nellis air force base they
say that this was
a contractor operated aircraft that
crashed
after taking off from nellis around 2 30
and as you said the clark county fire
department confirming that the pilot
did die now where we are we're a couple
blocks away from where exactly
this happened but you can see that metro
police and
airmen and the military are blocking
this street
and there are several emergency vehicles
down the way as well now we want to show
you viewer video that was sent to us
showing the fiery aftermath of the plane
crashes take a look at this
you can see the flames and a large plume
of black smoke
billowing into the air witnesses tell us
it was a terrifying
situation and we actually spoke to one
man who said that he saw the fire
and then decided to look into it further
and here's how he describes what he saw
and as i got closer um i was gonna get
all the way in and i heard an explosion
and it blew up and it scared me so bad
that i just i stepped back
uh because i immediately knew there was
still fuel probably
uh like everywhere
[Music]
so again a really scary situation for a
lot of the people that work
and live in this area we are hearing
from officials as well governor sissel
act tweeting out that he is praying
for those involved in today's incident
especially the men and women of nellis
air force base
and senator jackie rosen also took the
twitter saying that she is closely
monitoring
today's incident and again we are trying
to learn more details about what exactly
caused this plane crash any more
information we can get from nellis the
fire department
and police so be sure to stay with eight
news now for updates both on air and
online
for now reporting live orca mana 8 news
now